[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous avec l'été
arrive le soleil eux s'ils envie de lire
à ses dires c'est tellement important
victor hugo disait lire c'est boire et
manger
l'esprit qui ne lit pas maigri comme le
corps qui ne mangent pas donc à nous
sommes cinq passionnés de livres
nous allons vous essayez de vous donner
de bonnes idées de lecture pour cet été
tout d'abord avec suzy maltret qui est
poétesse et romancière nouvelliste qui a
fondé le salon des écrivains et des
éditeurs à rambouillet la onzième
édition aura lieu le 14 novembre oubliez
le 17e rang
donc elle enfin un très bon roman les
mains nues ou le dernier siècle
voilà je me suis dit qu'il était
inconcevable de ne pas trouver une
héroïne quelque part qui est traversée
ce siècle et je les trouvais dans
albertine native du cantal dans un dans
un environnement rural et à cette époque
là elle était née en 1913
on allait vers pas qu'ils remontaient
vers paris
on n'avait qu'une envie c'est d'aller
rejoindre la région parisienne
donc elle va traverser ce ciel jusqu'à
la prochaine guerre qui valent à
surprendre
voilà et c'est cette histoire là que
j'ai voulu vous faire connaître avec les
péripéties d'une femme qui sort de la
campagne qui ne connaît rien à la ville
mais qui va essayer de s'y intégrer
elle va donc rencontrer forcément ce
deuxième conflit mondial
elle y perdra une main je ne vous dis
pas comment ce nom sanaa plus d'attrait
bien évidemment elle y perdra une main
et quand vous regardez juste de la
couverture du livre
c'est à vous de deviner ce que et le
malgré tout est important ce qu'elle
deviendra voilà
et j'espère que les lecteurs trouveront
comme dans les critiques d'antoine de
matériel qui est un grand critique à
trouver dans ce livre voilà une raison
d'espérer en na'vi les menus comme nous
faire voyager aussi monicault ou ne
peuvent pas cet été je m'excuse mais
c'est plus un livre d'enfant honteuse
fait un lien entre l'afrique et la
ferons très bel exemple de l'association
pirouette vous faites beaucoup de choses
à écrire peut donc se livre ce livre a
été fait a été fait à settat collectifs
etc geneviève ceccaldi qui l'a qui l'a
aidé à le faire et se livre pas de
l'autre c'est sur l'autre et pour
l'autre et à travers des petites
histoires ça a été fait à la réunion
donc qu'ils ont pris d d d d animaux de
la mer et chaque animal a un problème
alors la souris tu es là cette pâte au
lieu de huit
dans la famille on dit qu'elles ont
honte le cac à toi tu es là un bec mais
il a hélas pas de bec email à des
grosses lèvres rose
quel malheur et dans la famille le
homard 4 passes au lieu de deux ça aussi
c'est la honte
la petite tortue au lieu d'avoir sa
carapace apparat sol indien
au lieu d'avoir sa carapace ah tiens un
parasol enfin chacun a un problème et
s'aperçoivent que ceux qui en ont trop
peuvent équilibrer avec ceux qui n'ont
pas assez les circonstances font qu'ils
se retrouvent tous ensemble et qui sont
issus et c et sont solidaires les uns
des autres ils chargent regard sur eux
et sur tous les autres changent regarde
sur sur eux mêmes
donc ce et je pense que les que la
différence les handicapés que ça passe
par les enfants et que ce cet été le
livre et gueye chèrement ce coloré et ça
peut permettre à des parents d'avoir des
moments intimes avec leur enfant est
d'abord dépassée
sur la plage et peuvent très bien
regarder voilà un très beau licencier
mon petit coup dans l'air c'est un très
beau livre sur le vivre ensemble
patrick ottaviani kawther romancier pour
être fondateur d'une maison d'édition
les trompettes marine va nous parler
d'un livre justement édité par la raison
alors ça c'est effectivement le c'est
notre cinquième publication trompette
marine un livre d'eugène dabit alors là
on va qu'on va quitter la plage pour
faire un retour dans le passé parce que
ce que nous propose jeunes d'abyssée de
12,12 compte qu'ils sont qui sont parus
dans paris soir entre 1933 et 1936 en
fait d'où ce conte qui se révèle qui
s'apparente à le nouvel et qui sont en
réalité des nouvelles et 12 12 portraits
sur 12 univers comment dire sur le
dénuement la pauvreté la solitude dans
les quartiers populaires parisiens et il
faut savoir aussi que eugène dabit c'est
le but aux éditions des trompettes
marine on veut faire ressurgir des
écrivains qui ont été très connu dans le
passé
eugène dabit avait comme pygmalion roger
martin du gard qui lui est qui lui
reprenait sans arrêt ses romans son
premier roman qui s'appelait petit louis
etc
et puis il était aussi avec andré gide
et cette hauteur là est mort
prématurément à 36 ans à sébastopol en
urss quand il avait fait son voyage avec
andré gide mai
qu'est ce que je veux dire oui alors
c'est publié aussi les nouvelles ont été
publiés dans le contexte du journal
paris-soir paris soir à cette époque là
le les les quotidiens parisiens il y
avait juste la tsf qui qui démarrait
mais c'était 20 millions de tirages de
journaux en france y avait peut-être 40
millions d'habitants il y avait quand
même 20 millions de tirages de journaux
et en 1900 en 1939
paris soir c'était le plus important
journal d'époque il a fait un million
neuf cent mille 1 millions 900 mille
tirage c'est l'ancêtre de france hors
paris soit c'était l'ancêtre de france
soir et puis c'était jean prouvost un
homme industriels du textile qui avait
racheté ce journal dans les années 30 et
qu'il l'a fait bondir en disant que
l'image était prioritaire dans son
journal était plus complémentaire de ce
que de ce que l'on pouvait écrire et qui
a créé paris match en 1949
en fait les 70 ans de paris match mais
sinon indépendamment deçà dans le dans
les livres lui-même donc cesser les
milieux les milieux populaires à paris
dans les années 30 35 40 etc des
portraits magnifiques parce que eugène
dabit qui est aussi qui a été au cas eu
le premier prix populiste avec hôtel du
nord hôtel du nord dont il a été fait le
film qui a été mis en film mais au
départ c'était son synopsis on peut dire
c'était
le téléroman qu'il avait écrit et
c'était une époque c'est donc c'est vous
avez des nouvelles avec la vieille en
particulier c'est des portraits qui sont
qui sont pris qu'ils avaient
véritablement il est poignant
il est très très à l'observation il
prend tous les petits que tous les tics
qu'ont les gens il est très observateur
et ça donne des rois des nouvelles qui
sont absolument magnifiques et hervé
lozach doc et scénariste réalisateur et
romancier peut nous parlait aussi d'un
livre intéressant dans un livret que
j'adore qui s'appelle les lunatiques je
sais pas si on le voit voilà donc c'est
un livre de mathieu de vilmorin ça a été
préfacé par philippe pozzo di borgo qui
est qui a inspiré enfin qui joue le père
qui a inspiré le personnage de françois
cluzet dans les intouchables paralytique
alors qui je vous dis juste un tout
petit extrait qui et qui très bonne
entrée en matière c'est avec humour que
mathieu de vilmorin traite ce sujet
difficile de la maladie psychique
l'humour le véritable antidote me dit il
ce livre porteur d'espoir et fait
connaître tout un pan de la société
constituée de personnes souvent
considérée comme inquiétante rejeter
hors de notre société actuelle où donne
une la norme
mathieu 2000 morin remettre en
perspective la présentation erronée du
public sur la schizophrénie - donc
mathieu de vilmorin c'est quelqu'un que
je connais en fait c'est un ami
d'enfance un ami de collège et je les
revues il ya très très peu et je ne
pouvais pas soupçonner une seconde et
lui-même ne pouvait pas le soupçonner
qu'il était atteint de crise de
schizophrénie
ça s'est déclarée il avait 23 ans et ils
sont nés guérilla c'est stable
maintenant il ya 5 6 ans et en fait ce
qui est extrêmement touchant dans ce
livre c'est deux choses c'est d'abord
l'aveu du fait que c'est une maladie
comme une autre qui peut s'est déclaré
chez chacun on est toujours un peu
borderline avec la avec la folie elle
peut toucher les alpina août il ya
toutes sortes de choses qui nous met un
petit peu en limite et lui voilà j'ai
une personne ne pouvait soupçonner que
ça lui arrive et ça lui arrive
et ce livre vraiment très très très très
beau très très touchant parce que il
il a en plus cette faculté d'être drôle
c'est à dire qu'il va d'un d'un simple
j'ai pas ça me vient à la seconde la
seule espèce de charlie chaplin quoi il
va il est trimballée d'un d'un hp à un
autre et ce qui fait c'est y croque les
personnages qu'il voit quoi et c'est
assez extrêmement bien écrit c'est
littéraire il y avait beaucoup d'humour
et c'est pas c'est pas un bilan c'est
pas alors il ya des bouquins qui sont
faits qui sont faits par des praticiens
qui explique la maladie bat à l'autre
qui sont faits par des patients qui
expliquent comment ils s'en sortent lui
il est en dehors de tout ça il croise
des personnages et c'est vraiment
vraiment très touchant vraiment très
drôle ça se lit très facilement
alors j'ai pas le temps de vous lire des
extraits ou des choses ou autre mais
enfin il ya des passages un moment donné
il y avait qu un patient il et il
voudrait faire le guide
le guide de l'ahp quoi alors illizi ce
disque pour avec avec des entonnoirs
comme ça trois entonnoir c'est le degré
de folie où on est accepté et voilà je
trouve cents et ménages très
bouleversant est très intéressant et
merci hervé et pour conclure l'émission
vous propose de redécouvrir et victor
hugo avec l'excellent livre de jean
françois kahn ne me sens pas mais c'est
passionnant
fo jean françois kahn était l'invité
d'honneur du salon du livre d'elancourt
de l'an dernier et nous faire découvrir
quand il était exilé à guernesey par
exemple les marins transportait des
poèmes de victor hugo dans leur poche il
vend des sae y risquer de la prison ça
fait penser à la résistance et il
explique aussi le seul mouvement
exceptionnel de victor hugo qui était
père de france financé par le roi et qui
est devenu révolutionnaire des grands
défenseurs de la république et c'est
passionnant avec plein de textes inédits
les discours de victor hugo parlement en
face et c'est énorme c'est vraiment à
lire pour redécouvrir et victor hugo
donc merci à toutes et à tous
encore un abonné bel été à tout le monde
et bonne lecture
merci à tout le monde voilà passé un
très bon été
[Musique]